Now that we've got this pure prototypal version of the car class, let's
refactor it into the very closely related pattern known as pseudo-classical.
The pattern we're about to build is called pseudo-classical because it
attempts to resemble the class systems from other languages by adding
a thin layer of syntactic conveniences.
If we plan on making a lot of classes in our programs, and we do,
there's a lot of code here that would get repetitive to repeat every time.
Perhaps the language could do more of these steps automatically somehow.
Which lines here seem likely to show up in every class you write and maybe seem
like the language could provide some mechanism for doing automatically for you?